THINGS.
>> Tucker: SECRETARY BEN
CARSON JOINS US TONIGHT.
MR. SECRETARY, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: AS YOU WELL KNOW
CONGRESSWOMAN MALONE CALLED
YOUR PROPOSAL, QUOTE,
DESPICABLE BUT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING IT'S ILLEGAL
FOR ILLEGAL ALIENS TO BE
LIVING IN PUBLIC HOUSING IN
THE FIRST PLACE, IS IT NOT.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
SECTION 214 OF THE HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
ACT OF 1980 SPECIFICALLY
STATES THAT THE SECRETARY OF
HUD IS PROHIBITED FROM
PROVIDING HOUSING ASSISTANCE
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
AND WHAT PEOPLE SOMETIMES
DON'T UNDERSTAND IS THAT WE
HAVE MILLIONS OF LEGAL
AMERICANS IN LINE WAITING
FOR THESE VERY SCARCE
RESOURCES.
WHAT CONGRESSWOMAN AND MANY
OTHERS ALSO DON'T REALIZE IS
THAT WE HAVE PROVIDED A
MECHANISM WHEREBY PEOPLE WHO
ARE AFFECTED, ILLEGALS WHO
ARE AFFECTED AND CAN'T FIND
HOUSING CAN HAVE DELAYED
ACTION FOR SIX MONTHS, WHICH
CAN BE RENEWED TWICE FOR A
TOTAL OF 18 MONTHS, WHICH,
OF COURSE, IS PLENTY OF TIME
FOR CONGRESS TO DO ITS JOB.
SO, YOU KNOW, FOR THEM TO
SUGGEST THAT I SHOULD BREAK
THE LAW, WHAT IS THE REAL
IMPLICATION?
THAT WE CAN JUST PICK AND
CHOOSE THE LAWS WE WANT TO
ENFORCE AND EMBRACE?
OF COURSE WE FEEL SYMPATHY
FOR PEOPLE.
OF COURSE WE DON'T WANT
ANYBODY OUT ON THE STREETS.
BUT, THE REAL THING THAT IS
HURTING PEOPLE IS OUR
FAILURE TO ADDRESS THIS
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
THE RULES THAT ARE DRAWING
PEOPLE HERE AND KEEPING THEM
HERE AND SO UNFAIR TO
AMERICAN CITIZENS PAYING
TAXES AND WORKING HERE.
WE TAKE IN 1.1 MILLION
PEOPLE LEGALLY THROUGH OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM, WHICH IS
FAR MORE THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY AND LET THAT SYSTEM
WORK.
IT CAN'T WORK WHEN WE HAVE
PERVERSE INCENTIVES DRAWING
PEOPLE HERE.
>> SO WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
SLEEPING OUTSIDE EVERY NIGHT
WHO ARE HOMELESS AND THEY
ARE EVERYWHERE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> AND YOU ARE TELLING US
THAT THERE ARE MANY
THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL ALIENS
LIVING AT PUBLIC EXPENSE AND
PUBLIC HOUSING AND CONGRESS
HAS SOME CONCERN ABOUT
WHAT'S -- I MEAN, WHY WOULD
THAT BE A CONCERN AT ALL?
FOREIGN CITIZENS BREAKING
OUR LAWS, WHY WOULDN'T WE
SPEND ALL OF OUR TIME AND
ALL OF OUR MONEY AND ENERGY
WORRYING ABOUT AMERICANS
LIVING ON THE STREET?
>> WELL, YOU WOULD THINK WE
WOULD DO THAT YOU KNOW,
WHENEVER YOU GET ON AN
AIRPLANE AND INITIAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS THEY SAY IF
THERE IS AN EMERGENCY OXYGEN
MASK ALSO DROP DOWN PUT
YOURS ON FIRST AND THEN
ASSIST YOUR NEIGHBOR.
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR PEOPLE.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE ARE
NOT COMPASSIONATE PEOPLE.
IT MEANS WE ARE LOGICAL
PEOPLE.
LET'S TAKE CARE OF OUR
I'M VERY HAPPY.
I TOLD CONGRESSWOMAN AND
OTHERS IF YOU CAN FIND A WAY
THAT I CAN LEGALLY DO WHAT
YOU WANT ME TO DO PLEASE
TELL ME WHAT IT IS.
I'M ALL EARS.
>> Tucker: HOW DID SHE
RESPOND?
>> CHANGED THE SUBJECT, OF
COURSE.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO WANT TO
DEAL WITH THE IDEAL THAT
CONGRESS IS THE ONE WHO
MAKES THE LAWS.
INSTEAD THEY WOULD RATHER
JUST SAY TO YOU WHY DON'T
YOU BREAK THE LAW?
SO THAT WE CAN FEEL GOOD
ABOUT OUR SELVES?
WHY DON'T THEY DO THEIR
JOBS?
THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE
ELECTED TO DO.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE A
REAL CHOICE TO MAKE HERE.
THEY NEED TO DECIDE WHAT
KIND OF PEOPLE DO THEY WANT
REPRESENTING US?
AND IT CAN'T JUST BE
SOMEBODY WHOSE NAME YOU
RECOGNIZE.
IT NEEDS TO BE PEOPLE WHO
ARE WILLING TO ROLL UP THEIR
SLEEVES AND DO THE TOUGH
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE DONE
IN ORDER FOR OUR COUNTRY TO
PROSPER.
AND WHEN OUR COUNTRY IS
PROSPEROUS, I THINK WE CAN
THEN TURN OUR ATTENTION TO
SOME OF THE OTHER COUNTRIES
AND SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO
HELP THEM.
BUT WE NEED TO GET OURS IN
ORDER, FIRST.
>> Tucker: SO CONGRESSWOMAN
MALONEY IS PRESSURING YOU TO
BREAK THE LAW.
SHE IS A LAWMAKER, SHE COULD
TRY TO CHANGE THE LAW.
SHE IS NOT BOTHERING.
ISN'T THAT PRIMA FACIE
EVIDENCE THAT SHE IS NOT A
SERIOUS PERSON?
THAT'S BUFFOONISH.
>> IT IS VERY SAD.
IT WOULD BE NICE IF SHE WERE
THE ONLY ONE.
BUT, THERE ARE MANY WHO FEEL
THAT WAY.
AND I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE
REALLY THOUGHT THROUGH
WHAT'S GOING ON.
THEY JUST ALLOW THEMSELVES
TO BE CAUGHT UP IN THE
MOMENT.
THEY WANTS TO BE POPULAR.
AND THEY ARE NOT THINKING
LONG TERM ABOUT WHAT THE
IMPACT IS OF WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
THEY ARE NOT THINKING ABOUT
OUR CHILDREN AND OUR GRAND
CHILDREN AND WHAT THEY WILL
HAVE TO FACE.
IT'S JUST WHAT MAKES ME LOOK
GOOD TODAY.